[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
breaking news
Joe bidening
wearing no show socks
can you believe it oh my God what would
we do without the media what would we do
without them
I don't know was he wearing socks or not
who gives a [__] are you [__] me are
you kidding me
he
someone takes a picture and it doesn't
look like Joe Biden's wearing socks and
that's the [__] you're gonna go with
holy [__] it must have been a slow
weekend
in the news good Lord and then
ah you see the you see the highlight of
the day we we put fast food
ah everyone's really upset that uh the
uh host of Diners Drive-Ins and Dives or
whatever the hell it's called Guy Fieri
dude's still putting frosted tips on
right like how the [__] didn't you know
he was the Kid Rock of Food Network come
on man
are you serious you didn't know that
speaking of that he's good friends with
Kid Rock apparently I'm sure they hang
out and drink Bud Light and do Bud Light
kind of things together I don't know
[__] you want from me
they make all this [__] up they make all
this [__] up what the [__] am I supposed
to do
they're still worshiping [__] Grandpa
poopy pants I get listen someone I don't
remember who it was but someone
commented on one of the posts uh over
the weekend because I always say look
we're at the intersection of
WrestleMania in real life
and there was no uh better
representation of that than this weekend
when Donald Trump goes to the UFC match
as if this makes him a manly man
I don't understand it look I get that
some people like fights and stuff
professional wrestling Boxing whatever
what the what the [__] the [__] eh you
know I don't give a [__] if that's what
you like fine whatever you want to do I
I mean
I honestly think it's dumb as dog [__]
to watch two
people beat the ever loving [__] out of
each other I think it's dumb but you
know whatever if it makes you feel tough
to watch it it makes you feel tough when
someone else
knocks someone else out you know
whatever I mean I'm not against punching
Nazis that's cool oh speaking of that
a lot of people are saying they don't
like the Indiana Jones movie it's mainly
fascist because he punches Nazis in
their apparently I haven't seen it yet
this is a sidebar there but I digress
look if you're [__] if you're [__]
surprised the Guy Fieri the guy who
still Frost his tips
oh my God man
he literally is the Kid Rock of the Food
Network and and you're surprised that
he's gonna try to kiss Trump at the UFC
match the [__] out of here man come on
give me a break
and and then the right Wingers are
really really [__] upset they're
really [__] upset that Joe Biden
appears shirtless on a beach in Delaware
it's really [__] weird isn't it like
okay all right so here's the thing
I missed this last week
but I found the clip
and I couldn't help be like holy [__]
Donald Trump did not know what a Dairy
Queen Blizzard was
okay
listen to All You Trump supporters out
there I get that you think he's the man
of the people he's not he's not he he
[__] hates your guts okay he [__]
hates your guts
he knows nothing about you he's he knows
nothing about your culture the only
thing that he does is is what you be
hateful and bigoted and ignorant he
gives you this this social [__]
uh permission
to be a [__] dumb [__] right
okay but he cares nothing about you he
knows nothing about you he knows nothing
about the way you live the struggles
that you have he knows nothing about it
not a goddamn thing now I could provide
all kinds of proof and you won't believe
me because you're like oh he's a
billionaire and he loves to speak the
truth and all this [__] nonsense
but um a few years ago in 2020 when the
Kansas City Chiefs
uh a team that it resides in my state of
Missouri okay Kansas City Chiefs are in
Missouri or Missouri or Missouri however
you want to say it the show me state
okay
Donald Trump got on Twitter if you
remember and was like hey yeah a great
state of Kansas which there is a Kansas
City Kansas okay there is one but the
people in Kansas City Kansas do not say
they're from Kansas City Kansas they're
like yeah I'm from Olathe Kansas
they make up some other [__] they do not
want to be tied to the metropolitan area
of Kansas City or even make it sound
like they're part of that part of the
metropolitan area
metropolitan area they they don't want
to be associated with the bad parts of
Kansas City you know what I'm saying you
know you you know they don't like black
people that's what I'm trying to tell
you the white Suburban folk out in
Kansas City Kansas don't like black
people that's what I mean
it's not [__] difficult to understand
these things now
the Kansas City Chiefs play
in Independence Missouri okay not in
Kansas City Missouri they are not even
near
actual Kansas City Missouri they are in
Independence which is way outside the
downtown area of Kansas City
okay it's kind of out in the middle of
nowhere to be quite honest in
Independence just just off the
interstate
the crazy part is is that everyone in
Missouri everyone who's a Chiefs fan
knows this they know this and he tweeted
out uh the great state of Kansas
congratulations to them for the Kansas
City Chiefs because it has Kansas the
reason why Donald Trump doesn't know
this
you you want to know do you want to know
the reason why he doesn't know this
is because Donald Trump would never
ever consider building a hotel in Kansas
City nor would he even consider Landing
his [__] plane there unless a bunch
of [__] toothless rednecks were
willing to give him money
that's it that's it he thinks Kansas
City Missouri Kansas are [__] [__]
boxes he thinks there's [__] States
he doesn't like you
he didn't know what a Dairy Queen
Blizzard was now I know you're like Tony
this that's kind of [__] ridiculous
to say that oh well you know maybe the
guy didn't know he just he prefers
McDonald's so why would he know what a
DQ Blizzard is
listen man if you're a fan of fast food
at all at all in this country and you
don't even if you've never had one man
even if you've never had one you know
what a [__] DQ Blizzard is
okay you know what it is
[__] didn't know the other thing
that he doesn't know
is what they do with the Blizzard at DQ
what they're required to do which is
turn the [__] upside down before they
hand it to someone didn't know it
not a clue
wouldn't know it why would he he is he
is a [__] elitist
you dumb [__] this blue-collar
billionaire [__] is a [__] fraud
now let's fast forward a bit to this
weekend
to the UFC match where he's oh he's a
man of the people look he L he rubbed
elbows with a bunch of celebrities
you
you [__] toothless brainless idiots
he's rubbing elbows with a bunch of
celebrities man
okay
and then you got Joe Biden who goes to
the beach in Delaware
he goes to the beach
he's such a normal average person
amongst normal average people because
that's who he is that's where he came
from Joe Biden's dad didn't own [__]
HUD apartments where the government paid
him to build buildings and then the
government paid the People's rent to him
all the while them trying to refuse
their Apartments to black people not to
mention that
Joe Biden didn't grow up with a silver
spoon in his ass you got it
so yeah when he goes to the beach in
Delaware he acts like a normal dude
because he is a normal dude
[__] reading books on the beach
and Maga gets pissed off I'm serious
he's reading books on the beach and they
get mad oh my God they're like oh look
at him reading him books he's so fancy
he's such an elitist he's reading books
but this is this is the outrage machine
on the right that Joe Biden goes to the
beach over the weekend
makes a couple trips to the beach he's
comfortable with himself that he'll take
his [__] shirt off and Lounge on the
beach with his friends and his family
have a good time
not being disturbed
normal average people knowing in
Delaware who he is
and look he's just there to get some sun
enjoy the beach We're not gonna [__]
with him this is not a show this is not
a [__] concert this is not
WrestleMania
he's the president United States he gets
up in the morning he puts his [__]
shoes on and he does his [__] job and
when he wants to relax [__]
hangs out at the beach a little bit
but this is who manga is
this is who they are this is why this is
why I keep telling you that this Primary
in the Republican party is over
Ron DeSantis cannot compete with the
[__] show
they want the show they want to be lied
to
they want the fraud they want to be
grifted they want they want to be
deceived they want the delusion
it's all a desire to live in a world
that isn't reality because reality makes
them very very uncomfortable can you
imagine how [__] uncomfortable it
would be for Donald Trump to show up at
a beach and him to get into some
swimming trunks holy [__] you talk about
an uncomfortable situation
the entire world will be like Jesus
Christ put your clothes back on you
[__] fat [__] that's what he would be
doing
but that's the key that's the key
is that Trump's supporters want to be
lied to they want the show they it's
WrestleMania
and real life that the intersection that
we're at it's here
just like wrestling fans right
professional wrestling fans they know
it's all [__] really
ain't ain't no it's not real in that
it's all rigged
but it's the show they want you know
it's the show they want that yeah there
might be a few people get injured
and and it's oh man you got to have a
really really high athleticism to
accomplish these Feats in the ring
but it's all it's all rigged it's all
you know just for show and we're
cheering
we're cheering not not because we want
one side to win or the other because
it's fun it's fun to love the bad guy
it's fun when the good guy loses right
it's fun it's fun and we love we love
being hateful and angry and bigoted we
love that and that's what Donald Trump
allows them to do
they don't care if he's a fraud they
don't care if he's not really a man over
people listen there has never been ever
in the history
of our modern day
someone who's a man of the people that
doesn't know what the [__] a DQ Blizzard
is
or what what they do with it when they
hand it to you
if you don't know that [__] you are not
a man of the people okay you are not a
populist you are pretending to be one
it's all a [__] fraud
and that proves it right there it proves
it now my guess is that he skipped out
on the bill again
because he was like what the hell are
these blizzards everyone keeps talking
about look at the [__] menu you dumb
son of a [__]
one Jesus Christ Joe Biden's reading
books on the beach and Donald Trump
can't read the Dairy Queen menu for
[__] sake
God damn is this really a [__] choice
we have Jesus and this is the guy they
want not only not only is this the
they're not the person they're going to
choose to be in their nominee they want
him to be the nominee they're begging
for him to be the nominee it's crazy
[__] we live in a crazy time it's a wild
time to be on this planet
absolutely wild dying to be on this
planet speaking of the planet
it is really doing everything it can to
get rid of us isn't it it really is I
think Mother Nature is going to try her
damnedest to [__] eradicate us holy
[__] no one day after another uh we we
top the hottest day on Earth right hot
as a [__]
the weather is weird
so much so that uh the king of England
and the president United States meet
today they're not going to talk about
the
war in Ukraine
they're not really going to talk about
anything but the dangers of climate
change now you know the the king of
England the king the king I don't know
why why did we still why are they serve
a [__]
have you figured this out yet
why why do they still have why do they
do that
does the king do anything
I mean really honestly what the [__]
what the [__] does he do anyways the
president of the United States you'll
find me to the king today to talk about
climate change
um as we keep setting records for
hottest day on this planet and again you
know a lot of people might give me [__]
about this but I'd go in the way of
George Carlin on this uh George Carlin
back 30 years ago said look we're not
going to destroy the planet I know you
think we're destroying the planet but
we're just pissing her off okay that's
all we're doing we're just pissing her
off she's been around a hell of a lot
longer than we have and she'll be around
a hell a lot longer than we'll ever
dream of okay we'll be long [__] gone
and she'll be here just a dancing you
got it
Mother Nature is not going anywhere
but we're pissing her off it's kind of
like the orcas we pissed them the [__]
off they're like okay enough of this
nonsense you [__] humans better get
your [__] together or we're gonna start
sinking your goddamn boats
get your [__] [__] together okay
but Mother Nature has had enough of us
and what what what better way to get rid
of us than to just cook us right I mean
that's the
that's the best way to get rid of humans
I mean who likes the [__] hot weather
right no no one likes that [__] you
don't want to be in a 120 degrees
temperature
inside
standing by your air conditioner in the
middle of December in Wisconsin come on
now I'm telling you mother nature is
pissed
she's [__] pissed
so you better get your [__] together so
I I and I like the fact
that the two world leaders
who may or may not control whatever
financial situation because that's the
that's the tough part about all this
is capitalism is not exactly the system
that you would operate to get the planet
not to be pissed off at us
but she is she's [__] furious she's
infuriated how couldn't you be like I
said I think she's I think she's got the
orcas on her side here
speaking of orcas we're going to talk
about orcas later on um today uh it was
last week or the week it had been the
week before we um
we had um
we we featured an orca down in Florida
and uh to free her or to clean her
[__] tank so we're gonna talk a
little bit more about that today someone
in the chat knows what I'm talking about
I told her to make sure to remind Gabe
every hour on the out no she said remind
Gabe every hour on the hour to make sure
we we talk about this today and then
hopefully she did that
oh how was your guys this weekend I had
a great weekend it was a great it was a
great weekend to watch
um the manga think that it oh my God
Donald Trump's showing up at a UFC match
paying who knows how much for tickets to
sit next to celebrities that makes you
qualified to be a president
but the guy who's taking a break from
actually doing the work of president at
the actual work who's one of the most
effective presidents in modern history
he's just taking a break hanging out on
the beach reading a book
able to take his [__] shirt off and
enjoy some rays oh that guy oh man [__]
him he's doing way too much for our
country to to rest
oh [__]
you know I'm not wrong you know I'm not
wrong
you know I'm not wrong
listen I was a little late uh to the
show today right I think I was a couple
minutes late I'm trying man it's Monday
I got my coffee here you guys are here
I'm glad you're here
I got some water too
um
we're gonna we're gonna get this show
done today we got two hours I got some
clips I want to show you from over the
weekend I've got Chris Christie uh
talking some [__] that's right uh we're
gonna see if Chris Christie throwing
some punches I got this uh I don't know
this video of this mom and her son
flipping off people uh saying all lives
matter some racist [__] I also got to
show you the Arizona college Republicans
are gonna invite Nick Fuentes
the Hitler sympathizer the Nazi
and his buddy the the the the the shaman
the Q Anon Shaman to their I don't know
to their speech thing I don't know this
is weird I mean you shouldn't be
surprised when they tell you who they
are listen
now I also want to show you
and turning points USA is having another
uh
um
fascist concert
uh and it's got they got all the they
got them all together they're doing like
CPAC types events every [__] week now
every [__] week so I want to talk to
you about that oh
did you hear Elon Musk thinks Zuck is a
cuck we'll probably talk about that that
uh today
I'm not kidding you he [__] tweeted I
also have a video I think we've showed
this before but I have a video we're
gonna we're gonna re-air it um it's been
going around the internet of a great
restaurant I think it's in Texas I don't
know
speaking of [__] restaurants when
we're talking about DQ Blizzards it's
called Trump Burger
oh it's so embarrassing and so pathetic
and then speaking of Trump's
uh did you know did you hear the news
that Donald Trump Jr and uh Lauren
bobert maybe um
you know what I mean you know what I
mean you know what I mean I mean she
just recently got divorced Donald Trump
apparently broke up where Kimberly give
oil and they show up this week in an
event in Colorado with a Bud Light truck
I'm not kidding you they were drinking
queer beer over the weekend Lauren
bobert Donald Trump Jr apparently what I
don't what do you want from me I don't
I don't get to choose these things I
just I don't
um we got some more Clips to show you
from some [__]
uh maybe even some [__] with
casseroles I I also again
I don't know if Gabe Sanchez is going to
show up in a wig or not but I've got a
video a small rant made on on Twitter
we'll probably air that today
as well we're going to talk about all
these things including probably dunking
on Ron DeSantis and some others don't go
anywhere we'll be right back
right after this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
trying to remember all the things you
boycotted can really get you stressed
because there's no good way to keep them
from becoming a cluttered mess well now
there's boycott binder the ingenious
organizer that keeps track of everything
and everyone you've ever boycotted the
72 category filing system makes it easy
to organize boycotted people places and
things so you can find them with ease
the large centered area can even fit
your boycott sign but best of all when
you're done the boycott binder folds
right up so you can take it anywhere so
if you're tired of having a cluttered
mess call now and get the boycott binder
for just 29.99 plus you'll also receive
our next rep as a bonus just Loop it
around your neck to travel with ease but
call right now and we'll double the
offer that's two boycott binders and two
neck straps for just 29.99 boycott
binders brought to you by the same
makers of binders full of women
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
socks or no socks
is it really a question
Jesus [__] crazy
[Music]
listen I I have a couple pairs of hay
dudes you know any dudes there
I don't wear socks with them
I don't wear socks with my hey dudes I
don't they they feel like like a um
like
like a really fancy pair of flip-flops
right
that's what that's what they do it's
kind of feel like to me they're really I
mean are they shoes they are
but they're kind of not
you know I I would I wouldn't wear socks
with flip-flops
I mean that wouldn't happen right
I wouldn't worry I mean some people
might some people might
they might
but I don't wear socks with hey dudes
you guys know what hey dudes are
some people are saying they love their
hay dudes uh William says I love my hey
dudes yeah [__] yeah man
that's what I like that's why I like
them because I don't have to put the
[__] socks on
what the [__] you want to wear socks for
I mean unless you're gonna get sweaty
and like you're going for a jog or some
[__]
no
hey dudes are shoes
they're shoes they're just like
lightweight kind of like canvas shoes
with a flip-flop bottom that's what they
are what do you want for I mean they're
listen they're
they're more than just that but
yeah
they're just [__] glorified
flip-flops and Christy says she has
three pair
I need three pair I got three three
pairs of hay dudes too
Christy we're on the same page I got
three pairs I got one that I I wear a
lot
my my go-to and then I have a couple
others so
um
look up hey dudes just look them up
they're nice shoes I mean they're not
like cheap and they got knockoffs right
they got knockoffs that are similar to
The hey dude brand that just the snot
the exact same thing but listen
does anyone remember Don Johnson and a
pair of loafers with no socks on that
was like the coolest [__] thing ever
right
that's like the coolest [__] thing
ever
some people are saying so hey dudes are
southern loafers well I mean
the brand is called hey dude and it
looks like you're a dude right you know
you're a [__] Beach Bum
so my ears let me show you let me show
you um here's Doug Mills with the New
York Times
here's the here's the tweet it says uh
POTUS boards Air Force One at Dover Air
Force Base I see the parts for London
England oh my God Biden was no socks
with his sneakers here's a picture of
the president United States oh my God he
doesn't have socks on
are you [__] kid listen the fact that
you [__] are even are even
form this tweet because of this picture
Doug he's with the New York Times folks
this is supposed to be a serious person
he was it's he no laugh Emoji no eye
roll nothing like hey I'm joking
he's got nyt New York Times in his
[__] handle
what the [__]
crazy [__] crazy [__]
I mean maybe maybe he just forgot his
flip-flops you know what I mean maybe he
just came off the beach from getting
some rays man
maybe he don't give a [__] getting on
the plane
to have some shoes on I don't know it's
so stupid wanna
I said this is tan suit type [__]
right
now again
it's really hard for them to attack
someone
it's re it's really hard for them to
attack someone
when they're going for the no socks
thing right I keep telling you folks
like there's no one that's gonna run
against him and I just keep getting
pushed back and like now we need to have
a primary he needs to debate Marianne
Williamson and JFK or excuse me RFK Jr
he needs to debate somebody
what he needs to debate somebody the
[__] out of here man
who the [__] is he gonna debate the
people who are pissed off he ain't
wearing socks come on
this is dumb as dog [__] if this is the
best attack you have well then you don't
have an attack
[Music]
maybe what you should do
maybe what you should do is pay
attention
to to the actual threat to this country
the Nazis oh my God that would be
fantastic
here's
here's Schaefer you guys know this guy
is a January sixer right he's also I
think he used to be a host or is a host
or some kind of producer with Alex Jones
Infowars right this is Twitter this
weekend
he posted this poll look what it says do
you oh my Jesus Christ
oh [__] I can't even believe
that you can post this poll not only
that but the results of it
and then the choices that he gave are
just
oh my God okay so he asked the question
do you believe Jews disappear
disproportionately control the world's
institutions Banks and are Waging War on
white Western Society
Schaefer is a Nazi I don't I don't know
if you can determine that from this
question but listen if you shape your
question in this way
right I don't give a [__] where you post
it I don't care if you just put it in
your private little messages
you're a Nazi okay that's what it is
you're a Nazi this is this is Hitler's
policy okay now look at the choices not
only did he write the question right
he thought about it he wrote it he's
like yeah this is
boom this is some grade eight Hitler
stuff
the [__] the
[__] choices here oh my God
yes no yes it's complicated and no it's
complicated what
what is okay yes it's complicated it's
like yeah I'm a Nazi I just don't want
you to know that I'm a Nazi right
because yes overwhelmingly
um to Schaefer's
um Chagrin here his supporters are
definitely Nazis or Nazi adjacent right
like 53 said yes 24 and a half percent
said yes it's complicated
so they're either they're either Nazi or
Nazi adjacent at best right
someone else posted a poll
down below to see the if people in this
thread in this in the replies how they
would react
now this is this is an actual way that
you would phrase a question right who
are the good guys in World War II man
really easy I mean it's it's really
simple stuff right who were the good
guys
the good guys in World War II this was
Schaefer's
audiences answer to this question
55.9 percent said the the Nazis were
good guys and then 44 said the people
fighting not not holy [__] [__]
now this was on Twitter over the weekend
okay so this is the hell hole that
Twitter has become
uh since threads started to catch on did
you know there's like a hundred million
signups on threads on meta's threads
look I I don't I don't I don't like Elon
Musk and I don't like Zuckerberg either
really
honestly
I could do without either one of them in
my life or in existence whatsoever but
here's the thing
so
if you're gonna pick one of them right
if you're gonna pick one of them that
you gotta deal with
I would pick Zuckerberg here's why
Zuckerberg is just a dork
just a dork right now he's a dork with a
lot of power and I think it gets to his
head a little bit
right
Elon Musk is a dork trying everything he
can to prove that he's not a [__]
dork right he's that [__]
he's that [__] [__] you know what
I'm talking about look hey just [__]
be who you are man don't try to convince
us you're something that you're not
you're not cool dude you're not Elon
you're not [__] cool you never work
cool you won't be cool it's just not you
no matter how many cigars you try to
smoke no matter how much shitty dancing
you try to do at concerts no matter what
you try no matter what how you prove to
your incel army that you're the baddest
of all badasses you're still just a
[__] dork
you're just a dork man it's okay
it's it's 100 okay but Zuckerberg
Zuckerberg is just a dork right and he
can't get out of dorkville
right am I right so that you know at
least you gotta say wow
Beastie he uh knows who he is I don't
know
oh [__] but this is the [__] that's
going on on Twitter
um also Elon called
um
Zuckerberg a cuck which is hilarious
isn't that funny come on man that's
hilarious that's great
he he called
he he called Zuckerberg a dork or no a
[__] excuse me
um when he's getting cut by threads
currently
Gabe Sanchez had it here here's the uh
here's the this is a real this is real
and he says Zuck is a cuck
look at it what the hell yeah okay well
I've got a I got a video to show you
[Music]
um
on this matter uh that uh this cuck
matter who's the cuck
it was given someone pointed out
this morning give me attention to this
so I want to play this here our friend
uh Justin t Brown uh found this
somewhere on the web so I'm gonna play
it here and take a listen
[Music]
maybe together we can get somewhere any
place is better starting from zero got
nothing to lose maybe we'll make
something me myself I got nothing to
prove
[Music]
foreign
finally see what it means to be living
[Music]
yeah I think you Justin Brown for
fighting that video for us and making
sure that we all get to enjoy it you
should go follow Justin not on Twitter
but also on threads are you guys on
threads yet there's 100 million sign ups
on threads it's [__] crazy
that's [__] nuts that's that's almost
that's almost half
of what Twitter's daily active users are
now there's a lot there's a lot more
Twitter accounts right
but that's the daily active users about
249 250 million I think
I think that's what it is maybe it's 225
something like that I don't know we'll
ask Gabe when he gets on here he'll be
on here in about 20 minutes
but uh isn't that crazy a hundred
million signups now I have to tell you
like I I don't have there's no desktop
version of threads yet so I can't like
show it to you here on the screen I wish
I could and why we'll get to that I'm
sure I'm sure eventually once threads
has the desktop thing we I probably
won't show you much of Twitter anymore
unless it's just the dumpster fire that
I'm showing you I might show you a lot
of threads right
we won't surf the Tweety tweets anymore
we'll surf the 3D threads I don't know
the [__] you want from me I didn't
destroy Twitter it's not my fault but um
threads is interesting because it feels
like a bunch
of lefties and a bunch of people who got
sick and tired of how much of a dumpster
via Twitter was thinks that threads is
going to be this social media Oasis
right and a lot of people are telling
people hey don't interact with right
Wingers don't don't comment on them
don't play their little game don't put
them in the algorithm right well here's
the thing
and I
you know I just have to be honest with
you if you are looking for
uh an oasis on social media get the [__]
off social media okay if you are too
[__] soft and too [__] sensitive
to see stuff that is going to offend you
get off social media stop it it's it's
not good for your mental health it
really isn't okay it's not good for your
mental health it just isn't get the [__]
off of it if if that's what it takes
because you're not gonna find a social
media platform that's gonna only show
you [__] that you agree with
it's not gonna happen listen algorithms
are garbage in garbage out okay you put
the garbage in and it feeds you the
garbage out
and the problem is is that we expect
everyone else's algorithm to line up
with ours it's not gonna happen listen
each individual thread user right let's
just use it as an example because it's
the new platform everyone's going to it
everyone loves it oh my God it's so good
on threads because there's not the Nazis
on threads
which you know I I could care less if
they're there or not like on Twitter I
just I don't want the sludge right it's
it's kind of refreshing to go to threads
and it's not so much the sludge
and the reason why is because the
algorithm hasn't got enough of your
garbage to feed you the garbage yet do
you you follow me are you smelling what
I'm stepping in because every single
user has their own algorithm
okay it's one algorithm but each account
has its own [__] algorithm which
means your account on your social media
let's just use threads as an example is
building what garbage you want to see
because frankly it's garbage I don't
care if you don't think it's garbage it
is
it's not objectively good it's social
media it's not objectively good
right it's things that you're wanting to
do to feed that dopamine rush in your
brain
I do it you do it right but here's the
thing is all of our algorithms are
smashing into each other a hundred
million of them on threads right now are
just smashing into each other Twitter's
the same way it's 250 million right and
it's easy to find it's easy to find
plenty of people on almost any social
media platform that disagree with you
vehemently no matter which side of the
aisle you're on rather you're for
Liberty and you're part of the
pro-democracy Coalition or you're just a
straight Nazi there's going to be plenty
of people for you to disagree with on
any social media platform and here's the
thing here's the thing
if you want to have a social media
platform that only only gives you what
you want and agrees with you every time
then stay the [__] off social media it's
going to help your mental health it
really is I take mental health breaks
off social media I I stop posting at
some points usually sometimes over over
the vacation that I had over Fourth of
July you guys notice I didn't hardly
post anything on social media it's like
[__] that [__] I didn't go read social
media
you gotta [__] take breaks because
it's not it's not exactly good for you
okay now
I'll tell you that gen Z this is one
thing that they understand and you can
tell it that they understand it right
they understand this fundamentally is
because they've never they've never been
alive without an algorithm right a lot
of us a lot of us are like what the [__]
is an algorithm right they've never not
had one
in their lives never not had an
algorithm I mean Jesus Christ there's
some of these kids that were picking up
their parents devices and flipping
through social media their parents
social media to look at videos or
whatever the hell
since they were one and two which is
building their algorithm
right
it's how it works now is it right is it
wrong it's it's reality
it's what we have to deal with but look
if you're looking for a social media
platform that's that's gonna cater to
you being happy
that's not what it's for
social media is not to make you happy
okay it's for you to see how happy
everyone else is
I know that sounds crazy right it sounds
[__] nuts but just go to any social
media platforms and you'll see this
happening
your social media platform is not
designed to make you happy it's designed
for you to see all the other
[__] out there being happy so
here's what you do either stay on social
media or be happy on social media so
everyone else can see how happy you are
right
and honestly if social media gets you in
this slump
because we all deal with depression and
I know I'm getting serious now
but this is something that we are
dealing with
and that's why it's an important
discussion to have because this this
threads thing folks it's not it's not
the newest greatest thing
it's the same as what we had before
that's it
it's just run by less of an [__] than
the other guy
then the other the other app with that
starts with t Okay so
as as this new experiment of threads
continues
to see where this goes stop
being so worried about what people think
of you
stop being so worried about what you
think of other people
stop stop
letting social media control you
okay be offended if you want to be
offended hell yeah be offended I'm
offended by a lot of [__] on social
media hell yeah and I [__] say it
loud and proud when I not that I'm
offended I just fight back
but no no that there's never going to be
a point in history where you're not
offended
know this
if if you're looking for a spot
in your existence where you will be
offended by nothing you will never
achieve it
you will never but know the threat
know the threat
know the threat don't be offended by
socks okay
or or the president United States taking
off his shirt lounging while reading a
book don't be offended by that
where you should be offended by is a
[__] fat fascist showing up at a UFC
match where two people Pummel each
other's brains into the mat
and rubs elbows with a bunch of [__]
celebrity elitist hmm that maybe or that
he doesn't know what a [__] DQ
Blizzard is that's offensive that's
[__] offensive let me show you this
let me show you this I'm going to show
it to you
I'm gonna show it to you I'm gonna show
you
um the DQ debacle now this is this is
not only the DQ debacle where he doesn't
know what a blizzard is but this is also
um well let me just say it's Poopy Pants
versus dark Brandon here this is what
this is now it's really quick but if you
catch it listen up real good here we're
gonna hear it everybody wants a blizzard
what the hell
yeah
there you go okay see this see this boom
that is Joe Biden what is he doing what
is he doing with the blizzard
he turns it upside down
and the reason why is because Joe Biden
knows what they do with a blizzard
because he he he's not he's not an
elitist
oh I don't know if you know that
I mean I know a lot of people want to
believe that that's it it he's not I
mean yeah has he been a politician for
many many years yeah sure and really
honestly for the politician that he is
for as many decades as he's been in in
the Senate and then the vice president
now the president he should be rich as
[__] and he's one of the brokest
politicians in in Washington and he's
still got a ton of money
right okay oh oh some sick of it says it
says Joe probably loves blizzards hell
yeah dude's down on ice cream who the
[__] not down on ice cream if you're
not lacked [__] even if you are lactose
intolerant you should be down on ice
cream
and I'll I'll tell you that that uh a
Cookie Dough Blizzard chocolate chip
cookie dough Blizzard from [__] DQ I
don't get paid this is not an ad for DQ
I'm just saying
a chocolate chip cookie dough blizzard
holy [__]
good stuff man that's that's the that's
that's good stuff
that's good [__] but clearly clearly
dark Brandon knows what a blizzard is
but this guy he says what the hell is a
blizzard
really and we're supposed to believe
he's the man of the people come on
come on man come on man okay so let's
I'm gonna show you the uh
the UFC and uh oh wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait
um this is um this is Grandpa passing
out
um what does that appear to be are those
blizzards are those blizzards he's
passing them out they're going let's
take a listen
[Music]
oh oh man he's he's he's
he obviously doesn't know he obviously
doesn't know what a blizzard is oh my
God okay oh boy oh boy I think I
ah YouTube's totally gonna ban me
they're gonna [__] ban me aren't they
will you guys come to another platform
if YouTube bans me
whatever you want I like to laugh I like
to have fun what are you gonna do
[__] [__] that [__] listen
if they do ban me which they they likely
will you can watch us on Facebook at the
Tony Michaels follow us on Facebook if
you still have a Zuck account over there
on Facebook
follow us at the Tony micros you can
watch it over there you can also watch
us on Twitch there's a lot of people
been watching on Twitch lately we got
more and more followers more and more
subscribers it's free to follow us on
Twitch this is kind of weird I know I'm
doing a plug here
um but bear with me
so twitch it's free to follow us on
Twitch but if you want commercial free
watching on Twitch uh and if you have an
Amazon Prime account here's what you can
do you can actually tie and link your
Amazon Prime account to your Twitch
account it's really cool what it does is
it gives us a couple extra bucks a month
that's right well here's how it works
twitch it's free to follow but it's 4.99
to subscribe now you can go over and pay
for the subscription I wouldn't
recommend it if you have a Prime account
because when you have an Amazon Prime
account you get one free subscription
every single month with your Prime
account through Amazon gaming on Twitch
so here's what you do you link your
Amazon account to your Twitch account
and you have every single month a lot of
people need to resubscribe but every
single month you resub re resubscribe
over there on Twitch just go to Twitch
they'll tell you how to do it in the
chat or you can go to the Tony
michaels.com that's the Tony
michaels.com and you can find the
directions there it's like the fourth
link down
like the fourth one down right there you
can click that
our our great moderator the mighty
librarian gave you directions not on not
only on how to link them but there's
also directions on how to resubscribe
every month takes like two seconds great
directions there at the Tony
michaels.com so uh Kelly Downing and
resubscribe this morning looks like uh
we had a couple resubscribes this
morning and also some new newcomers
there uh to Twitch so thank you very
much for all the follows all the support
because if they do kick me off YouTube
we'll have to go somewhere I don't know
if twitch is the spot we'll have to go
somewhere so make sure to subscribe to
YouTube and watch us every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
for two full hours
and you know what if you want to follow
us on Twitter you can
if you're still over there at Tony
Michaels pod
or you can follow us on threads at the
Tony Michaels and at I am Gabe Sanchez I
think we're gonna set up the Pod account
over on threads too
I think we're gonna do that we'll
probably do that too eventually you know
why not [__] it
I'm willing to give Zuck one more
account just
add to it add to it okay
um let's see I have some more Clips here
that I wanted to show you
um
because it's very important snuff as you
know
here is um here is uh the
the Cheeto dust q and honor
um at Council Bluffs Iowa at one of his
rallies let's listen to his projection
here it's [__] astounding a man we
have a president of the United States
who's a stone cold corrupt favorite and
oh man how the [__]
okay the dude stole our documents he
refused to give him back and then he
obstructed Justice
he's a thief he's a [__] thief like
the definition of thief like he's being
charged with felonies because he stole
[__] and wouldn't give it back
okay let's let's see what else he
projects here
who's willing to arrest his opponent a
man we have a president of the United
States
ah willing to arrest his opponent like
literally their whole thing
was lock her up and I watched several uh
videos of people asking Trump supporters
hey hey if you if you got a chance
um for Joe Biden to be arrested would
you want Trump do that you got damn
right lock him up and all that [__] you
know I don't know
I thought I had one of those ready to go
I honestly thought I did
somewhere see that's the problem with
threads and Twitter right now is I don't
know what I've watched it on threads or
what I've watched on Twitter you know
what I mean and I'm and that's the
that's the shittiest part about it so
far it's like if I find something on
threads I'm like oh okay that's that
account now I gotta go over to Twitter
and find it over there because I'm like
I want to show the audience this this
thing how the hell you know what I mean
and it just and man it um
it's it's it's getting kind of rough if
you want to know the honest truth if you
want to know the honest truth okay here
here's one of the interviews that I
found on the weekend this is
embarrassing as [__] but watch this
Trump supporter watch watch the
justification that he makes for Trump
okay watch uh so you I'd Rather Be An
American than a Democrat
I assume you're saying American
Democrats aren't Americans
no the Democrats just want socials and
that's not American okay
okay so uh uh let's stop there
old man mcfashy
um decides that Democrats are socialists
right because they want free everything
that's what they want they want free
everything
oh boy they really do have these people
brainwashed
um but oh grandpa mcfashy here
um with the sign that says I'd Rather Be
An American than a Democrat I don't know
what the [__] that means really honestly
he clearly doesn't know what it means
either
um but let's listen to his explanation
of what socialism is because oh boy it
gets it gets fascinating Social Security
in America you're on Social Security
I am but I work but I work a full-time
business I know but you're aware of
social uh Social Security is a socialist
program well that's beside the point
that was oh I asked beside the Boeing
okay now you know okay so he clearly he
clearly he clearly commits to I hate
socialism for other people here is what
he clearly
he clearly commits to here and the
reason why is because it's not good for
thee but it's good for me and all white
all white all white I'm a white old man
I am entitled to my socialism okay I'm
entitled to my socialism I bet that's
what he says next let's see just said
you don't want socialism that's fine
that's why I don't want socialism across
the board are you gonna go give up your
Social Security tomorrow I would give up
my Social Security if I had to okay I
don't think in the point you're saying
you don't want social okay here's where
this this is really important this is
really important folks now this guy
stands there and he's not really serious
he's not being serious because he's not
a serious person because again I keep
[__] telling you I keep telling you
we are at the intersection
of WrestleMania and real life they don't
care what's real and what's not they
just want it to appear to be weird
real but it's it is weird
they want it to be real and they want to
be able to pretend that it's real
that that Social Security isn't
socialism because I'm getting it it's
socialism when someone else gets it
right but listen socialism but you're
enjoying it no no you you are on a
socialist program wait a second no I'm
not because I paid into social security
for 50 years before I started drawing
off of it
all right all right okay here we go here
we go now now he he turns right so he
makes the argument that Social Security
is socialist and then he's like no it's
not it's not socialist because I paid
into it okay it is socialist dude this
this is this is part of socialism this
is what socialism in a capitalist
society looks like now it's not
purebredded socialism I don't know you
guys know that or not uh but it's not
it's not pure breaded socialism
purebredded socialism is that you you
wouldn't have to actually work a certain
amount of quarters and pay in a certain
amount to get this benefit
um but you know that's neither here nor
there here's the thing is that this man
believes that it's not an entitlement
because he paid into it now when he sees
someone else
maybe with a certain skin color certain
religion certain gender I don't know he
might think well they didn't pay into it
so they don't get it
again it's not socialism to him because
he paid for he worked for it but listen
when this person explains to him
why it smells like socialism that he
likes right right but it's
redistribution young people right now
young people I earned it okay so but you
agree it's a socialist program the
Veterans Administration is a socialist
program the veterans Healthcare you know
what the veterans deserve everything
they get they're the ones that stood up
and fought fought for you and I so we
can stand here and talk freely we're in
agreement I'm just saying we already
have socialist programs that you're
that's fine a few of them are fine but
not across the board which ones are you
afraid of and the health insurance
business for 30 years we cannot afford
so oh he's been in the health insurance
business for 40 years has he hmm and he
knows because he's been in that business
that we cannot afford health insurance
for everyone and the reason why is
because if they did that oh boy it would
really hurt his business yeah man it
really hurt his business if I don't know
then we took him out of business if we
took away his way to make profit he
probably this brainless idiot wouldn't
have to figure out a way
to make a living [__] stooge
socialized medicine can we afford
endless war we cannot we cannot afford
single-payer health insurance could we
afford endless war we spend Six Trillion
in Iraq and Afghanistan were you out
here talking about that President Trump
isn't looking for that either he's
trying he's trying to pull everything
back what are you talking about the debt
has exploded under Trump the debt is up
double you know what that might be true
but but he's also created far more
business than anybody in history and and
as the business grows the business taxes
will pay that off but you gotta
understand no no but no no let's just
talk the facts though it takes a free
economy to pay to pay off debt right but
if what he's doing is mostly
deregulation and tax cuts for okay if
you're wondering what's going on here
if you're wondering what's going on
again when when Grandpa poopy pants says
[__] into the internet machine
and these people gobble it up on Fox
News because this guy's not on Twitter
this guy's not on true social more than
likely he's just he's just watching Fox
News
okay probably oan probably some Newsmax
peppered in here and there right okay
but this guy knows not a goddamn thing
but what he wants to hear
I don't know how many times I have to
tell you this
I know how many of these clips I have to
[__] show you
and tell you
morons well listen to me
and mainly the media is who I'm talking
to here
and understand that Donald Trump is
going to be their nominee okay I don't
care what poll you [__] talk about I
don't care what kind of [__] proof
you show me oh well historically I don't
give a [__] we're not dealing with
historical data here
we're dealing with how Cults work okay
it's a [__] cult this guy goes all
over the [__] map to try to explain
to you why he's justifying his reasons
that he's going to vote for a [__]
bigot
for a [__] fascist for someone who
would spit on him if he had the [__]
chance but he worships him
he worships him
I bet this guy actually knows what a DQ
Blizzard is
it's manga guy I bet he knows what a DQ
Blizzard is I bet he's had a few in his
life probably a couple this month
and I would bet if you ask this
[__]
if you asked him what do they do with a
blizzard before they hand it to you
a Dairy Queen rather you're at the
counter and then drive through what do
they do with the blizzard before they
[__] hand it to you
this guy would be able to tell you that
he would be able to tell you that
but he can't manage to work up enough
[__] courage because he's in a cult
and he cannot defy the cult leader
okay
he can't defy the cult leader that is
why they're not gonna vote for Ron
DeSantis
forget about it forget about it Ron
you're [__] done man and people are
[__] jumping [__] on Ron's campaign
because Ron [__]
his launch went over like a wet fart in
a white thong even Casey DeSantis that
[__] weirdo his weirder wife can't
pull him out of the Abyss here really
trying like Ron went out there and he
was a weirdo like God damn you're
[__] weird man get your weird ass
wife out here maybe she's not as weird
and then like whoa she's just his weird
it's almost like you weirdos
married each other because you're
weirdos it's kind of
they're not gonna you know this guy's
not gonna vote for Rhonda Sanders you'll
never convince him of that let's watch
wealthier people which that's what the
tax cuts were for that people who create
business and jobs for you so why is it
why is it that such a large portion of
America where minimum wage jobs to high
a little over minimum wage wait and you
have an exploding income inequality in
this country if the wealthy people are
creating the jobs why are so many people
okay I appreciate this interviewer I do
and I don't know exactly who this is I
like to actually get them on the show
and the reason why I like talking to
them in private too dude you're not
you're not you're not doing it correctly
you're not doing it correctly
throwing facts at these [__] idiots
giving them data trying trying to get
them to agree with how reality works
it's not gonna work it's not gonna work
you have to appeal to their deepest
seated hatred is what you have to do
these people are hateful they're bigots
they want to be hateful they want to be
bigots they want to be angry
okay that's just what they want and the
reason why is because you keep saying
they have privilege and they don't think
you do until you start trying to take it
away and then they're oppressed right
it's it's it's a weird time and it's a
wild time to be alive folks
but this is not the way you handle these
guys right trying to tell them [__]
that's true with a microphone in their
face that's not gonna work
that's not gonna work I mean what would
work good good liars does a really good
job at this Walter does a really good
job at this and I'll show you some of
their videos but let's finish this one
up and then I'll show you that one
people living paycheck to paycheck
that's a has been has been their living
paycheck to paycheck yes because it's
coming around the other way it's taken
time I told you we have more more people
working today than we have had in
history we've got fewer people on
welfare and and fewer people uh Korean
have fewer people on welfare than in
history
where have you been looking at your
statistics uh the Bureau of Labor and
statistics see see again and I'm I'm
just gonna stop here and the reason why
is because this does no good this is why
I don't I this is why I don't give you
[__] facts and data and polls here on
the show
because it's it's all [__] um here
is here is Nashville Tennessee talking
to people here is um uh navram with the
good liners and he's talking he's in
Nashville he's talking to this guy with
the uh the New England Patriots hat on
here and the Cabela's shirt now this guy
looks like he would have a really hot
take when it comes to drag shows in
Tennessee but listen when he forms this
question
what this guy says listen we are here in
Nashville Tennessee talking to people of
the the recent
lump drag performances
feel about that
stupid but it's government overreach
let people live
boom you see that you see that that that
is the way that you get it okay now this
guy might have given that answer no
matter how he framed it but that's how
he framed the question it's how he
framed the approach and then boom
because frankly all these Patriots out
there these big we hate big government
you need to you need to come to the
Democratic site okay you need to start
realizing that the Republicans are the
big government party
they're the big government that wants to
be in your lives every single step of
the way they want to tell you what books
you can and can't read they want to tell
you what curriculum you can and can't
learn they want to tell you what history
you can't and can't know they want to
tell you who you can and can't love they
want to tell you how many kids you can
and can't have they want to tell you
what health care you can and can't rule
not you your wife your sister your
mother they want to tell them what
healthier they can and can't see or get
all right these are all they want to
tell you what religion you can and can't
be what religion your kids can and can't
be
what religious things you can and can't
see
okay they also want to tell they also
want to tell you who you can and can't
be what you can and can't wear what
bathroom you can and can't go into
this is all weird stuff this is all big
government in your lives in your
britches down to your genitalia type
weirdo [__] and it's what they want this
guy understands it that it's big
government [__] he gets it it's big
government [__] stay the [__] out of
my life
I'm telling you folks
I'm telling you you want to win you want
to [__] win in this country you want
to beat trumpism you want to beat this
[__] Theocratic fascism in this
country like down in Oklahoma Jesus
Christ have you seen this [__] this
goddamn superintendent of schools that
in Oklahoma this [__] holy [__]
you you talk about a goddamn Nazi God
damn
talking about the Tulsa Master we don't
want to teach
that it had to do with race are you
[__] me
oh man I could go on that tangent all
day long all right let's um let's go
speaking of the um
the cult here I want to show you this
you guys know um
there's this guy oh my God in West
Virginia his name's Derek Evans oh Jesus
this [__] guy is CR he's such a
[__]
such a goddamn little fruit loop right
Derek Evans he's a Jan six Patriot this
guy this guy stormed the capital he went
to prison for it
he actually took a plea deal
uh and he didn't go to trial this guy
took a plea deal so you get a lesser
prison sentence went to prison uh for
storming the capital trying to overthrow
our election because his God and savior
his mango Mussolini Jesus
um he he you know
he wanted to make sure he was the king
of the United States He also he also is
a former member of the West Virginia
House of Representatives I'm not
[__] you he says he's a Conservative
Christian which I believe he means I'm a
Nazi he's on true social and he's the
Republican candidate for United States
Congress in his district folks this
guy's running for congress on the
treason ticket I'm not [__] and that's
what they should do they should change
their party name
from Republicans to Traders instead of
D's and ours we've had D's and D's but
Derek here is on the trader ticket
for Maga he loves him some Trump oh my
God Derek just salivates over Trump now
he actually posted the video of trump
coming into the UFC fight you can see it
here
um and again I I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna play the sound to this thing but
this is him coming in yay I I got I got
I had paid a lot of money to sit next to
celebrities instead of you know hanging
out on the beach with my wife my family
amongst the you know normal normal
people instead of these [__] weirdos
who like watching people getting pounded
in the face
um but Derek says no one can compete
with this
dude every week on cable
professional wrestlers come into a crowd
of people cheering like this man
you know man right
foreign
like every week every week professional
wrestlers come out to this type of stuff
and oh by the way as someone else put in
the uh in my thread here let me see if I
can find it because I said this I said
girl how many times did you come I
thought Derek was saying he jerked off
to this that's what I thought
I I didn't I don't know how am I
supposed to tell what am I supposed
how am I supposed to right
I can't
I can't guess every single thing
uh here's woke Jesus baseball it was
their response in the in the thread to
my response I want to read it to you
says no one can compete with this dot
dot dot except the guy who beat him by
over seven million votes flipping five
states Trump won in 2016. why are right
Wingers so obsessed with losers they
love losers so much that's because Jesus
they're losers
they're [__] losers
that's why they love King loser here
but Derek Derek doesn't understand what
competition is he has no clue
he has no idea he has no idea that
average Americans don't give a [__]
if a dude comes in to eye of the tiger
or whatever music this was I don't know
what music they were playing
and a and a bunch of people who like to
watch other folks get pounded in the
face
like him
this is not a thing that that gets the
um people going okay all right
oh French here points out on Facebook
drag queens are actors and actresses and
just like anyone else that does play in
New York and Hollywood
turn on gay and they're not lesbian they
are not trans Oh I thought
sorry I thought you were going into they
they come in like this
drag queens man all the buzz man it's
quite the show when you go to a drag
show it's quite the show it almost looks
like Trump you know a trump drag show
it's kind of not really you know it's
it's got less toothless redneck bigots
at it you know most people are excited
though
at the drag shows just like the the
Sheep are excited at the Trump trump
drag shows you know I'm talking about
the Trump drag shows you know what I
mean
that's what I'm talking about like the
Nazi rallies that he has
he's in Trump drag by the way
some people are wondering where Gabe's
at why are you guys so concerned about
where he's gonna be here he's running a
little bit behind he'll be here don't
worry don't worry speaking of uh weirdos
here's a video going around the
interwebs I'm not sure where this is at
um
but you talking about [__] groomers
watch this I think this is the the
little boy's mom here but we'll listen
to the kind of the [__] that they spew
s
[Applause]
okay is that enough is that all you need
to see
um wow this um and you talk about
groomers and Dr Richard bittickoffer
said that the best grooming yeah of
course it's grooming this is what it is
this is what it looks like
um it's all projection when they're
saying that you know the truth is
grooming our children and education and
teachers our grooming our children
you're so [__] full of [__]
you're so [__] foolish [__]
listen listen let me let me show you
what Mass psychosis is would you would
you [__] listen I know a lot of
you in the chat like Joe Biden some of
you tolerate him some of you like you
know he's the lesser of two evils but
most you're like yeah he's a pretty good
prison he's pretty effective he's done
this this this this and this right ah
yeah he's good at his job right but
would you
would you drive by a place and it said
dark Brandon burgers or Biden Burgers
would you be like wow that's the place I
want to eat
no it's it's not a cult but trumpism is
a cult watch this this is embarrassing
come with me for lunch at the legendary
Trump burger and I walked in and I was
immediately taken back it's really funny
I mean Trump stuff everywhere the whole
menu is centered around Trump
it's all centered around Trump
oh my God you gotta be kidding me right
now I've watched this video before and
I've seen pictures of of the restaurant
I've actually went and looked it up
looked at the menu it's pathetic
oh man it's [__] pathetic
I'm surprised that Donald Trump hasn't
sued them yet
for his likeness because his name's on
it and I don't know if he has anything
to do with it
maybe one of his shell companies on this
but this is [__] weird watch this guy
at the end watch him watch it's really a
fun place man and I mean look at this
you got the Trump name on the bond
branded this is a giant burger it's two
eight ounce patties and four slices of
cheese wow
Trump Burger I'm gonna give it big
thumbs up it's in Bellville Texas you
can get your ass over here and get you a
burger I got the Trump Tower it's a
double meat it's really big thumbs up
how [__] embarrassing
how [__] embarrassing is this with
the watch with the sunglasses
come on man
you couldn't get oh my god do you
remember do you remember um you remember
Tiger King we were talking about Tiger
King and then I just I just thought of
this this is in Bellville Texas Tiger
King is in Oklahoma so they're they're
pretty close
do you remember the part on Tiger King
where Joe Exotic opens up a [__]
Pizza Joint right he opens up a
restaurant at his Zoo you remember that
and the [__] are like yeah
he was using meat off the meat truck
the tiger food remember because Walmart
and all the grocery stores would give
him like expired meat and [__] because
they had to throw it away so he would go
get their expired meat and he'd feed it
to the [__] tigers and lions right
well on the show they're like oh yeah
that [__] was totally using that
[__] on the pizza right so when you got
like a triple meat pizza that's probably
what's going on down to Trump burger
right
that's got to be what's going on is they
got a meat grinder in the back and then
just go in the grocery store getting all
the expired meat grinding that [__] up
what do they care I mean it's like
Lauren bobert's [__] diarrhea sliders
out there in Colorado
whoosh Trump Burger holy [__]
I just I just I keep trying to tell you
guys
I keep trying to say it's a cult
it's a [__] cult but you you won't
listen to me
what am I gonna do I don't know all
right so
um speaking of Lauren bobert and
diarrhea sliders
[Laughter]
position I don't know if Gabe will be
here
um he said he's he's got held up with
something so he'll be on here in a
second
um speaking of diarrhea sliders
you know that Lauren brobert's getting
divorced right and she's a grandma
apparently
um
Donald Trump Jr apparently separated
from um Kimberly Guilfoyle whoosh
I'm not sure who the winner is in that
separation you know what I mean Donald
Trump Jr and Kimberly Guilfoyle I'm not
really sure who is the winner
in that separation
but over the weekend
um Bobo the Clown and booger sugar
Junior here
had an event together
and some people are speculating that
they're probably bumping
uglies now my question was a lot of
people didn't like it but I mean
I think it's a legitimate question
you think he's done lines off her ass I
don't know how am I it's a legitimate
question right they keep talking about
cocaine they keep they can't [__]
focus on anything but no socks uh Beach
lounging and cocaine in the white house
like this the only thing on their minds
right now right
they can't stop talking about Coke Don
Jr can't stop talking about Coke on so
he's like it's not my cocaine I wish it
was the one that was found in the White
House I wish it was but it's not my
cocaine so I think this is a legitimate
question
you think he's done lines off her ass
already
I don't know I mean I'm sure
Ted Cruz might have
what what do you want from me the
Republicans are the ones that have the
cocaine sex orgies in Washington Madison
cawthorne told us about it he told the
truth and they outed him from the party
they wouldn't let him reseat
as a congressman are re-wheel you know
what do you want from me
okay so
um
it seems like
the recent breakup
and the divorce of Lauren bobert we may
have a reason to believe that that's
what this is but the other thing I
noticed was some other pictures that I
think
um Patriot takes posted okay so this is
one of the ones I believe
so here's a picture of the event of
Lauren bobert sitting with Donald Trump
Jr looks like they're having a swell all
the time doesn't it
you know what I mean
I don't know I think so but I noticed
something in the background up here I
noticed something in the background uh I
was like what the f what the [__] is
that that's a [__] Bud Light truck
now a lot of times Bud Light
uh they have like trailers and their
cake trailers I don't know if you get
guys have ever seen these they'll roll
them into like a big party so they'll
drive it in and it's and they they plug
it up and it's it's refrigerated they
got kegs in they got the Taps on the
outside right so that way it's like a
it's just a big beer bar on wheels that
they wheel in right pretty simple I've
seen them before at events uh but here's
here's that same picture but if you zoom
in look at there
it's Bud Light
it's Bud Light and what appears to be
Donald Trump because you see the red tie
in the suit
I don't know I thought that might have
been Donald Trump
could it be
could it be right
I don't know it seems like that could be
or am I just off my rocker
well apparently I was proven wrong
that it's it's even weirder than that
let me see if I can find it here
because Patriot takes had it yeah so
here is um
here's Patriot takes this is the actual
this is what actually it was and you see
here you see here that it's Bud Light
and it has these are the Taps here
these are the Taps here and then it says
uh it's Joe Biden with the sign that
said I did that
I I don't I'm not really sure what any
of this
uh Patriot takes Joe Biden invented
bloodline I'm not sure it's really
[__] it's weird stuff man I'm not
gonna lie to you I don't know what it
means now it may mean that they didn't
have the taps
because if you look really close if you
look really close the Bud Light truck
has no Taps on it
see there there's there's Outlets here
but no taps
and then there's mixers over here so I'm
not sure what the hell's going on
with this
but they had Bud Light at this at this
thing I don't know
it's [__] weird
just the observation that I made
oh so between me wanting to know if uh
Donald Trump Jr has done lines off her
ass and the um
the Bud Light thing I'm I'm the insane
one
apparently okay okay yeah okay yeah I'm
the insane one all right
um but here is um
here's a picture
of the president of the United States
enjoying
ah just uh lounging an afternoon him and
his wife
enjoying the sun enjoying the beach as
they would
and they're reading some books
it's so scary
they're reading books look at them
look at them they're reading books
uh so this is one picture from the
weekend now this was posted by um
Rebecca and she says I was at the beach
yesterday while a famous guy with a
house in the neighborhood was hanging
out nearby okay so did you hear that
a famous guy with a house in the
neighborhood
this is the beach that Joe Biden goes to
folks that's why when people were on the
beach they weren't swarming him also
because they were trying to enjoy some I
don't know private time and I'm sure
Secret Service was not wanting people
anywhere near them while they're
enjoying their time on the beach okay
but Rebecca points out that he has a
house he has a house nearby
present and Dr Biden are enjoying the
sunshine
about 50 yards away from where her
family was sitting so there's a picture
of them reading on the beach now I said
to Rebecca's tweet Brandon is reading
it's a really scary manga because I I
believe that's really what would I think
that's that's what the scariest thing is
now they circulated a video of Joe Biden
on the beach this weekend I'm going to
show that to you don't worry I'm gonna
I'm gonna show it to you
I'm gonna show you this video of them
freaking out about Joe Biden is willing
to take his shirt off
and get down to do the dirty you know
what I mean and I'm gonna show you this
is uh Joe Biden porn here um Gabe
Sanchez he's finally joining us uh I
don't know if you've been paying
attention up to this point but no I've
been in I've been in a bunker man that's
why I figured I'd throw in the Joe Biden
takes a shirt off to some porn that way
you'd be like whoa whoa what is this
video oh I know I've seen I've seen the
beach Brandon video oh so you've seen
that you've seen okay yeah you've seen
this yeah the surfer Brandon okay so so
here it is this is the video that that
the right wing was circulating around
like oh look look look Joe Biden Joe
Biden he has a beach chair on the beach
which is really weird and then then he's
loud look look what he's doing he's
leaning back in the chair to absorb the
vitamins D sunrays this is from the same
[__] Gabe Sanchez they had an
hour-long show when Tucker Carlson was
still relevant they had an hour-long
show on how to tan your balls man
and they're freaking out that this guy's
on the beach with his shirt off come on
yeah it's it's a little weird I mean you
know again a little weird a little a
little Obsession their obsession with
uh
uh naked men
and genitalia and again like no judgment
if that's the life you live and that's
the thing that you want go for it right
however don't attack people and then on
the flip side like Glory or like uh
glamorize and fetishize Donald Trump
with no shirt on and [__] Rambo oh
he's like Rocky or whatever it might be
so you're talking about the AI images
that have been circulating around there
listen AI images I'm not just yeah I'm
talking about the ones where they
literally put his face on Rambo or oh
yeah that's true Rocky Balboa because
like you look at this and it's like okay
here's a guy you know that goes to the
beach like any other person
this weekend yeah that's what it is but
but at the same time
I gotta ask you I gotta ask you are you
gonna do the Demonic Democrat thing and
and and get on your cell phone on the
beach is that what you're going to be
doing huh I mean there's only there's
only one way to do it I mean if you're
gonna be part of the cabal that the
requirement is that you Lounge like this
okay and that you're on the cell phone
on the beach where Where is the secret
like how far is that the Secret Service
is that one I'm sure this guy right here
is Speaker service that's the other
thing that's really weird about this
because I just showed a picture of um
someone who was also at the beach I
think on a separate day it was a
separate picture where Joe Biden and Dr
Jill Biden are reading together
and they didn't have their shirts off at
that point oh oh by the way by the way I
wonder he's got his sneakers on here on
the beach I wonder if he's wearing socks
or not I wonder if that's
I don't know did he wear a tan suit
after all I don't know I mean I'm sure
if he's not if it's not one
fashion faux pas it's another right I
mean that's what that's what Republicans
care about they're like look let me tell
you right now let me tell you how
somebody should be and how they
shouldn't wear this clothing or how they
should wear these shoes or it's like
dude I don't [__] care man I don't
give two shits about that stuff but the
fact that your party the Republican
party is so obsessed with someone's
genitalia what clothing they wear what
shoes they wear whether they wear them
with socks whatever they might be the
fact that you're so obsessed with those
little fine details right those those
judgmental details about someone's
fashion style or status or whatever it
might be shows you how little
Republicans actually care about everyday
problems right you look at Margaret
Taylor green
Lauren bobert they're [__] they care
only about impeaching Joe Biden on
things that were around during Trump's
Administration
um these are people that are not serious
people okay I I keep thinking back to uh
to to succession where there's a scene
at the at this final season and they're
in this karaoke room and he's like
you're not serious people and that's the
Republican Party none of them are
serious people they're never talking
about serious things or real problems or
solving problems you've got Joe Biden
going through a tour of America talking
about the chips Act and talk about how
manufacturing is going to be done in
America and Republicans are the ones who
fought against it fought against
American jobs fought against
revitalizing the manufacturing industry
specifically one that competes against
China the thing that Republicans always
say oh man the CCP this the CCP that and
when it comes down to it they're the
ones who immediately say no I won't back
the thing that's going to bring actual
life to the economy well don't tell the
media what the chips Act is because then
they might have to [__] get some
decent [__] questions you know
gathered up
and not do some stupid right-wing
[__] capitulation listen this on Face
the Nation here this [__] bonehead if
you're still watching face Nation you're
a [__] idiot but listen Park is
reliant on its greatest adversary for
key things for missiles for computers
electric vehicles yeah do we need a
domestic industrial policy why don't we
have one oh oh man you're the game why
don't we have a domestic policy where
we're not relying on um other countries
for things like I don't know well let's
see let's see what the answer is here we
do have one Margaret that's what the
chips in science Jesus Christ Biden
signed into law last year that the
Congress moved forward on a bipartisan
basis has delivered 10 and okay Chris
Coons in a manner of I don't know what
five seconds is like what though talking
about we had there was this big camera
around the kitchen there was a whole
thing about infrastructure
well hang on do you do you want to know
do you want to know why the media sucks
do you want to know why they suck
this is why they suck and the reason the
reason why this makes them suck
is because she knows that
she [__] knows that she knows that
there's the chip act she knows exactly
what you're saying she knows that [__]
she knows it but In the Heat of the
Moment In this interview that she wants
to sensationalize with Senator Chris
Coons here she's like she's just gonna
pretend it doesn't exist and hope he
doesn't bring it up hope that he doesn't
bring up the actual thing that Democrats
work their asses off for that
Republicans voted against and then they
come out and they're like oh you didn't
do [__] you didn't do [__] for American
manufacturers in American jobs get the
[__] out of here man let's finish up the
the clip here and then I'll let you tell
the audience why the chips act matters
because I I know you've been in this
industry before and not only just
industry but it affects all Industries
just like she was bitching about tens of
billions of dollars of new investments
in onshoring semiconductor chip
manufacturing a record number of new
Advanced manufacturing sites in the
United States there is more work for us
to do on this in this Congress and
Senator Schumer and Republicans in the
Senate are leading work on that so we
have turned a corner on having an
industrial policy in the United States
that brings back manufacturing that's
the core of bidenomics of okay so tell
us he didn't get into the details of why
it's so important that these
semiconductor chips are manufactured
here and one thing that led us to
believe this and I know you're going to
touch on it here is what happened during
the pandemic but tell us why why this
policy is so important why to keep
building on it too
yeah so the reason that this policy is
so so great is because the last you know
I don't know several decades China
specifically Shenzhen which is the the
uh
the chip manufacturing kind of center of
China is wherever wherever there is
electronic component that you know comes
out of the computer I'm on or the stereo
you work on or and you're [__] in
your [__] coaster in your [__]
toaster whatever it is all of these all
of these uh you know that are either
working on semiconductors or
microcontrollers or other various chips
they all come out of this same area
right and it's a manufacturing Hub where
it's an industry that has been built
only for that purpose it is where you go
when you're looking to manufacture
something and you need those specific
electronic components or you work with
manufacturers say hey look I need to
fabricate this one microchip or
microcontroller or whatever it might be
and you say it has to fit within this
you know schematic and they say great
okay we'll work with you and we'll
customize it
in America we don't have that well
actually okay that's not true we can
fabricate in America except it's very
expensive because we have not
specialized we have not gone to the same
scale that we have in China so when it
comes to com competition so what you're
saying what you're saying is is that
they're we have tooled them to build
these chips we haven't tooled ourselves
right we don't have the we don't yeah
we've tooled yeah we tooled them because
they they put in the infrastructure to
build that industry and we never did
that and so we said great it's cheaper
Market our demand our demand fueled
their factories
right and so now God forbid Joe Biden
and the Democrats have a policy in place
and and an actual uh economic growth
factors that they want to put into our
country to say great we no longer want
to be dependent on this other country we
no longer want to be dependent on
someone else to manufacture the thing
that we can do here and again we do we
can fabricate except it's very expensive
what might cost me Pennies on a dollar
to to manufacture a microcontroller or a
semiconductor would cost me tens if not
you know 20 or whatever dollars
depending on what the size is in in the
components this almost here in America
this almost feels like that we're trying
to factory the demand here is this going
to create American job it feels like to
me that this is going to create it's
it's almost in the same way in the same
way that Republicans attacked in the
same way that Republicans attacked the
coal industry to say we need to protect
or not not attack but when we said hey
there's like 30 cold jobs out there and
we want to now transfer those people
into another renewable energy industry
like solar
Republicans said no no no we have to
protect these coal jobs even though
they're dangerous
they meant co-miner they meant the mine
owners that's what they meant the owners
I think at the end of the day there were
more RBS employees in the country than
there were coal miners in the actual hey
hey hey hey I keep telling you with your
facts and stuff man you're gonna piss
them off man so so when it comes back
when it comes back to the chips act the
reason that it's so important is because
as a competitor just like we were and
you know coming back into being an
Autumn like the automotive industry
right the car industry being a
competitor this One-Stop shop where you
can go and say great I want to build my
car here I want to buy my car here I
want to do everything related to the car
here the reason that we have such a
an impactful opportunity to be seen
through the chips Act is because those
chips go in everything and one of the
main things that you see them go into
are the cars that you drive today right
whether they you know you have a smart
electronic system that controls
everything in your car from the engine
to the ace right well any every time
Lumberjack whatever it might be every
time your [__] engine light comes on
it's one of those [__] chips on a
sensor somewhere like that's what it is
and guess what those chips do right when
when it when your car has check engine
or you need this thing to be fixed it
records that on a log right it's just
it's just a list to say hey there on
this date at this time this item in your
car
hit a flag because there there was oh
God forbid we put some sort of
uh
we put some sort of system in place to
say if it goes above or below this
normal level we should flag that and log
it so that when you take it into your
car manufacturer or an auto you know
repair shop or whatever they can go
through they literally plug that into a
tablet and they go great okay we saw
that the engine line went on on July 5th
at 402 pm and it hit when it was you
know the conditions were the car was
this hot or it was this or there's all
of these variables that feed in so when
they get the car they can make an
informed decision God forbid we take all
of the information all of the data in to
make an informed decision so that we can
give you back a better thing and that is
what we're doing with the chips act and
that what is Biden has done with the
chips Act is we are creating an industry
we are creating jobs here in America and
not only that but in the same way that
Democrats look that said hey we want to
convert we don't want to we don't want
to get rid of your coal mining jobs we
want to then bring you in to the Future
right we want to take you in to
renewable energy and we will train you
and we will teach you exactly how to be
experts in solar and win in hydro and so
that going forward you will be experts
that can then be hired for these other
jobs or train other people for these
jobs going forward and that's the same
thing that we're doing with the chip
sacks is that we're thinking ahead we
are God forbid we plan ahead something
we want to accomplish and say great in
order to put ourselves in this place we
have to put the infrastructure and the
resources right now so that 10 years 20
years down the road we are a competitor
with China right I mean we are decades
behind China right now because they have
had all of our money all of our all of
our uh uh work and uh they have been the
places that we have gone to because it's
so cheap and they can manufacture things
so quickly at scale and we can't do that
and so that's what we're that's what
we're trying to do here is trying to be
a world
like even with a world competitor not
just someone who does uh specializes in
making small units or small
manufacturing runs of something right
cost you a lot of money because for so
long that's what was made here was just
a very very very uh specific uh types of
chips I mean a lot of the times a lot of
the times that people are making chips
in the US is when they're trying to
prototype it right they say hey I've got
this idea and I want to go to a shop I
want to yeah I want to go and then I
want to go manufactured in China because
it's hell of a lot cheaper over there
right and I have the capability of doing
it on a mass scale because the
infrastructure is already there Mark
said something on Facebook and I don't
know what you mean Mark I don't know you
too China full stop I don't know what
you the U is I have no idea I but I said
we I said we we tooled China we our
demand see this is how economic sources
have capitalism works it's it's hard to
explain to some people sometimes like
supply and demand there is no supply
side economics China didn't build a
bunch of Chip factories and were like
hey now you can come buy them from us
that's not what happened see what
happened was is we hear just what Gabe
said invent prototypes invent products
that need parts that need you know
pieces of material to make the things
work sometimes the pieces are made
somewhere and then they're sent
somewhere else and then they're
assembled but what I mean by we've told
China is we paid for their
infrastructure with our demand
and what Joe Biden has done with the
chips Act is said no we're going we're
going to Tool our country we're going to
Tool our country and our factories with
our demand as opposed to build the
infrastructure in China which sometimes
you can't get around building
infrastructure in other countries
because it is going to be cheaper to
build it there and you're trying to get
a product in a certain price point to
bring it to Market that's also
capitalism see that's also part of the
the equation in capitalism and
specifically you know uh during the
pandemic when I was so for instance I
was at a company that built uh
components that would go into smart
objects so in your house you might have
a smart coffee thing or a smart dog
feeder or a smart whatever it might be
right you're the TV that you have I work
for a company that created the software
and the hardware that would go into
those uh those those pieces of
electronics okay they were the they were
the Connecting Point to say I want this
object to connect to the internet we
were that Hub and and we
we had to shut down production because
of covid right there were many things
that happened in place but specifically
you did not have it you did not have
people buying objects you did not have
people buying these products you did not
have Manu you did not have factories
manufacturing them which means that at
the time these semiconductors were
dropped in a significant decline in
terms of production so that when things
did come back up there was a shortage
and that was an opportunity for the U.S
Joe Biden and Democrats to say hey look
there's a shortage in the world right
now and we are all everyone are
dependent on China to produce these
things and if everyone is requesting
these at the same time after it had just
been shut down during covid we're going
to have a supply and demand issue which
caused a shortage to which they said
well [__] why are we not doing this
right now let's make the investment
right now so we can make we can start
making these semiconductors and other
chips in the U.S so that not only we can
do these domestically but if people
outside the US want use us
awesome
so I got to get to the Orca story
because I I promised our friend oh yeah
but here's the thing here's the thing is
that Mark he's really confused he's
really confused he thinks he's seeking
attention here he said he's in it Mark's
an attention [__] and I don't know
where Dustin nowhere on Facebook is that
this must be one of Dustin's best
buddies it seems like it because he's a
[__] brain dead idiot he said you've
got a he's got a he says Hulk a Polk
High School I don't even know if that's
really him but right now who knows Polk
High School football jersey on yeah well
uh you know one one of those long lost
lives in high school when he was a great
guy in high school he peaked then Mark
Shelby says here on Facebook you tooled
China full stop he retyped in when he
typed in I just responded good luck
trying to do that when you have to pay
workers five times the money okay Mark
so are so are you advocating that we
keep the factories and jobs in China are
you advocating that we bring jobs over
here and are you mad that they would be
good paying jobs are you saying that we
shouldn't pay people good money that
people should I think capitalism Tony
Tony
capitalism has taught Mark yeah he
doesn't need to despite the fact despite
the fact that Republicans complain about
oh we don't have jobs we don't have jobs
we don't have jobs but on the flipside
coin the flip side of the coin you know
the 25 cents they're willing to pay
someone to go work for them on the flip
side of that coin they're like okay we
can't pay these people more money you
want to bring jobs here well no no they
don't no no no no no they don't want to
bring jobs here now because that would
mean that that Biden would get to win
look what he says here he says in which
presence which and which presidents were
in power when all this was happening I
don't I don't know if you know American
history Mark hey I really can't tell it
doesn't seem like it because you forgot
to fail to mention all the way back to
the person who got us uh in in the love
bed with China he was a republican I
don't know if you remember this guy at
all I don't even know his name maybe you
should just read contemporary history in
in your history book but Nixon is the
one I mean that's assuming Mark can read
right Nixon is the one who went over and
and made sure that communist China uh
was was yeah that guy that guy and
really honestly America owes uh deep
apologies to Nixon for framing him up as
one of the most corrupt people in our
country's history that had power in this
country we now know that holy [__] Nixon
doesn't hold the candle to Mark's
probably great great Jesus Mussolini
Jesus uh uh Trump because he's he's
doing all the Trump talking points here
here's what he says and which presidents
were in power Clinton Obama Bush all
anti-American hacks that cared more
about donations than America hey hey
dude hey dude hey Mark Mark you should
vote for Joe Biden next year Joe Biden
is the one who's bringing jobs back from
communist China you [__] idiot
Jesus Christ dude what can I mean he's
in power Joe Biden's in power he's the
president he signed the chip sack which
is going to bring millions of jobs and
open up tons of factories including in
Marjorie Taylor Green's District they're
going to open up a [__] chip factory
Marjorie Taylor Green's District Mark
maybe you should move to Georgia and get
you a job at that [__] chip plan you
and you'll make five times as much man
okay Mark really honestly I love having
you here man and keep commenting we like
when you say stupid [__] I love it I
love when you [__] idiots who think
you're free market capitalist you people
think that you're Freedom Fighters and
Patriots come here and say the most
anti-freedom anti-capitalist [__] in the
chat dude you're not talking to some
[__] socialist here you're not
talking to some dumb [__] leftist you
stupid bastard okay Mark so keep coming
buddy keep coming maybe one day one day
what I'm saying will make it through
your thick [__] skull okay I I really
there's another thing that I gotta I
gotta take care of here another piece of
business before to the Orca thing
there's a comment
and it's really a question here from
twitch it says did Gabe buy Tucker's I
like wood set what the hell is going on
it really does look like you're in the
Tucker Carlson I love woodworking yeah
what can I say you know I I I I love
wood
there you have it folks I I didn't
expect that to be an answer but he loves
wood I will tell you that I think that's
a Sound Studio right and that's the
reason why uh there's not as much yeah
people don't know this but wood has
sound dampening qualities a lot of types
no this whole this whole I'm literally
in a Sound Studio right now I've got
wood I've got panels above me yeah all
around me and these are panels behind me
I mean this place is like you could hear
a pin drop in the room now but what we
want to know what we want to know is how
is urine Tucker's excursion going now
that you're there at his Studio oh it's
pretty good he's hiding the closet right
now good is he is he fly fishing while
you're wired he's literally in the
closet
okay well
he's waiting for the show to be over and
can be like then he comes out and does
he does his shitty video speaking of
that real quick before we get the orcas
did you see did you see the Tucker
Carlson like every episode he released
just tanks it's getting worse yeah yeah
well it goes I wonder what it could be
I've been to I've been debating about if
I should do it what was that but like
there was a there was what we talked
about recently which is about the The
Impressions and the idea that if you
look at those videos that he released
the first one was big and then they
slowly went down down down down down
down down
and the idea that they were saying oh
this is the biggest show when it's
competing with mainstream media and
these networks and all this and that
it's not because they're Impressions
which is if you just scroll by and you
see it that counts as a view you don't
even have to stop and watch it you'd
have to wait for three seconds or two
seconds or whatever and and remember
that he's also releasing 10 minute
videos 12 13 minute videos yeah it felt
like he was getting longer and longer
like he was getting longer and longer to
try to get to like 30 minutes or
something minutes and 40 minutes and
then it was like nobody has the ability
maybe no retention skills or the the uh
the ability to stop and say oh great I
will I will zone out everything else
like I've got on Twitter that that's why
that's why I was saying in the beginning
and I I yell and scream it I said it in
Mario's rooms when they brought up hey
you have a show how do you like the Elon
lunch more shows on Twitter I'm like
well that's great but it's Twitter's not
set up for that they're like what do you
mean I'm like it's not there's a reason
why Twitter landed on two minutes and 20
seconds they didn't just like pull that
out of their ass it's no telling how
much money they spent to figure out the
exact time that they needed to have for
a video length
it's also it also only goes to show you
the desperation that Elon has right now
he's going after uh Mr Beast which if
anyone knows Mr Beast is one of the
largest YouTubers is the biggest
I mean he's the biggest yeah
but if you look there's a there's a
tweet exchange between him posting and
then Elon and Elon being oh like come to
Twitter and we'll we'll pay you more
competitive prices than than YouTube
where's the money coming from Elon
where's the [__] money coming from
the other thing too that's funny about
that is Mr Beast with his YouTube
channel is an actual self-made
billionaire Elon is not that's the best
part about it I gotta get to this
orchestory I promised our friend we got
to talk about it
um and I don't know if she's still in
the chat or not she was here earlier so
I hope that she's still here or that she
shares the video
um but this is important we covered this
story a couple weeks ago
um Lolita and orca down in Miami is it
down in my yes it's Miami and it's
called the Miami Seaquarium is what this
place is called and
um someone flew a drone over this uh
orcas tank and hasn't been cleaned in
Forever it's [__] nasty
um she's she's been held in captivity
for like 30 some years pretty pretty
much her entire life has been living in
this tank she lost her partner she had a
partner the right partner right in the
tank and she's been alone she's been
alone for decades now and and it doesn't
seem like they're cleaning the tank she
was bringing attention to it they
actually blocked her I believe they sent
the cease and desist uh and we're gonna
sue the Drone the person who took the
Drone footage um but there's gonna be a
protest for to set uh Lolita free on
July 15th from 11 to 2 I don't know why
they picked times I guess maybe they
have a permit
um but this this Orca needs our voice as
she says in the video here and I want to
play this
um so you guys know about this so you
can spread the news around we all
remember Lolita right it's it's been a
week since I last posted about this well
for all of the people who are asking how
help aside from writing sending letters
or emails or just straight up bullying
on the internet which is kind of what I
what I'm doing
um there's a protest coming up July 15th
11 A.M to 2 p.m I believe this is being
organized by urgencies no it totally is
I don't know why I said that they're
literally the ones who sent this to me
Evan gently Doug Hanks at the Miami
Herald has a Fluff piece coming out
defending the animal abuse at the Miami
Seaquarium
is it Seaquarium Aquarium
it's a dumb name don't believe the
propaganda don't believe the pr twist
get your signs ready all those
pro-lifers I expect you to be there
because every life is is sacred right
get your asses there that whale is
living in crap conditions she should
never have been in captivity in the
first place that there are no excuses
there are no reasons for delay no
justification
that whale needs to be set free Miami
Seaquarium
you should be ashamed of yourselves
uh well there it is and uh so go support
if you can be at the protest to support
the protest and if you do go
um take some video I I I hope yeah Dara
has someone that's going to be taking
videos so we can show it uh I really
want
um Lolita to be either get her [__]
tank clean or release her I really want
her released like if you're gonna
because the whole thing comes over is
like this company that took over they
promised
to to maintain the a you know good
healthy livable conditions but also the
release so they have they have not
fulfilled any of those promises that
they've made when they took over so this
is very important and I'm glad that
there is is we all remember playing this
out and I'm glad that there is a protest
because without truth right
like where where would we be right now
and and the ability for the attempt at
this company and this fluff piece to
silence the truth from coming out is
very trumpy and like uh you know the
idea that they would say no no this is
this is this is not what you think is
actually happening right it's the same
thing that our what was the guy's name
mark that was on here earlier is that
what he was I already forgot what his
name was well yes it was Mark Mark shell
Mark right Mark Mark Shelby who appear
who appears that he peaked in high
school that's why he's got his right
right of course yes but when I when I
saw when I saw him make that comment on
the coverage of China and the chips act
I thought to myself he would be the guy
that would totally be counter protesting
the release right of Lolita absolutely
he would be the guy that would stand
there and say no no no capitalism great
and and you know uh imprisonment of this
and and human or animal rights
violations are good and we should
definitely not make this animal's life
any better than it already is because I
wanted to be shitty shitty shitty and I
don't want to pay workers any Fair wages
and I want Trump to come back and I want
China and it's like
you you you stand for the complete
opposite of what you think you're
standing for well let me let me show you
I I mean I got a few my uh Mark here
there are some there's some bangers here
let me uh
oh there's some bangers he says Elon has
the woke Democrats buying his cars and
then turning around and disses them hey
Mark I don't know if you've looked at
Tesla's like their sales or their
marketing tactics but they've had to
lower the price on all their vehicles
because no one's buying them you [__]
buffoon I just saw I just saw an ad I I
last oh my God Friday Friday or Saturday
I saw an ad on Twitter that was telling
me about how the prices were lowered by
you know a few thousand dollars to make
the cars more attractive is Tesla buying
these ads
I believe it was Tesla so Tesla's buying
the ads on elon's platform to let to let
all Elon Simpsons know hey man you can
get one of my shitty cars for a lower
price now please go buy them because no
one else in their right mind will buy
them because all these all these uh
legitimate auto companies out there are
actually manufacturing EVS that are
going to be great but that's that is the
thing that we're seeing here is there's
a trend when you offer or or when you
offer the only product or when you take
the only product and make it shitty yeah
or if you take the only product and what
you stand for is shitty it will bleed
into your brand there were there was
literally the the interview I think it
was a month and a half ago or a month I
I don't quote me on the exact time it
was MSNBC and the question was from from
one of the correspondents you know at
the Tesla Factory said to Elon Musk hey
do you think that maybe you want to pump
the brakes on the tweets right now do
you think that like shareholders and the
board think that maybe the things that
you're saying or are questionably
causing brand destruction Maybe not
maybe not hurt your sales with your
mouth in other words exactly and he took
a he took a moment where he was like it
looked like he was trying to compute he
was like he's like I remember this scene
from The Princess Bride and it's like
whoa dude stop talking to me no you you
and then it goes to yeah well you know
I'm I'm excited about I'm excited about
this nonsense affecting their brands I'm
excited about it because we finally get
to know who they are uh like Charlie
Sykes here the [__] uh the Arizona look
at this Arizona college Republicans
United oh I'm sure it's just a fancy
organization out there in in Arizona
let's see who their guests speakers and
supporters by the way are gonna be oh
it's gonna be Nick Fuentes and the j6
political prisoner Jake chansley oh man
that is one hell of a look Arizona
college Republicans we are Nazis and we
like Nazis and we're supported we're
supported by Nazis we we like Nazis
and then also it's we support
insurrectionists right we support people
who go in
in a crazy costume cosplaying as a
patriot but really you're just someone
who's trying to obstruct what the actual
rule of law is when it comes to
certifying the election that happened in
2020 and you're going to take Jan six
political prisoner Jacob Chancellor and
you're gonna put him front and center to
go and look I have listened to this guy
speak on a few different Twitter spaces
oh my God holy [__]
it's wild man dude he was talking and
one in one Twitter space he was talking
about a movie that he had seen but also
Hollywood biting a chunk out of a
woman's ass I was like what is this how
did we get onto this timeline Tony
because right now I'm honestly at a
point where I look at this like you know
[__] reset the timeline I don't care
if Unplug Me from The Matrix like what
the [__] is going on because the fact
that we are platform in and putting this
guy on a pedestal within the Republican
party shows you exactly what their
ideals and their morals and their ethics
are and where they stand because they
certainly don't care about the American
people and they certainly don't care
about democracy right well when you when
the Arizona college Republicans United
uh decides that it's good for their
brand to have Nick Fuentes an outright
Nazi who went on several podcasts with
with Kanye West declaring that they
loved Hitler that's not my [__] words
that's theirs that they loved Hitler
he's an outright Nazi he's a holocaust
denier that that this is good for your
brand whoa [__] you have slipped and
then you have the Q Anon Shaman holy
[__] this guy you talk about and you're
right some of the [__] he says in these
spaces
I mean wild [__] wild wild [__] I have
to say what I mean they're they were
there are moments there are moments
where I I look at the timeline and there
were statements where it's like I used
to make statements with the utmost
positivity like
anything's possible and now it's like
wow anything's possible
time to be alive damn
what a time to be alive you know really
we have gone a complete 180 and how you
know I I do have hope I do have hope but
I
this is something that needs to be
called out right something that we call
out on the show something that everyone
else is watching and listening should be
calling on an everyday basis in the fact
that there are these people who are
fascists there are these people who are
trying to oppress you in various forms
of society if they're trying to suppress
your vote they're trying to take away
your rights they're trying to strip away
your own Humanity if you're part of
groups like if you're gay or trans or
lesbian or whatever it might be they are
trying to take those things away so that
you can be the vanilla cookie cutter
boring straight religious
Nazi hey speaking of religious Nazis I
gotta answer this question before we go
because I know we're over time sure yeah
and I know the audience is dying for us
to do another hour but I know you're
you're with family and you you need to
go but I ain't got to ask you this
question because I asked the audience I
asked the internet this weekend I want
to know your opinion do you think he
snorted lines off her ass I just do you
think
I know it's a good question I formed it
myself my friend I made this question in
my mind
think I I man it's a see the fact is
when you texted me or when you sent me
that tweet this weekend yesterday yeah I
well yeah it was funny because we sent
it in your life
you're like you thought about this and I
was like whoa you thought about him
snorting you're like no no no no if they
were bone and not the cocaine snorting
thing I'm like okay oh man honestly I'll
just say it like this in this timeline
anything's possible
that's what it is there there is a I
don't think I don't think that well who
knows honestly because when I look at
the situation supposedly there's rumors
of of Kimberly Guilfoyle and Don Jr
breaking up that hasn't been confirmed
yet they've been engaged since the end
of 2021 they announced in the beginning
of 2022
yeah
[Laughter]
oh man she comes here for work but she
leaves on buttons but I just don't think
that they can I do not think that they
can go that route and make this public
privately yeah sure maybe maybe they're
snorting I you know I I honestly believe
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait baby junior maybe I'm
missing it Gabe maybe I'm missing the
actual question here that we need to be
asking
not that did he snort cocaine off her
ass
did she snort cocaine off his ass this
is where you come for the best political
commentary
uh on the planet uh frankly that's what
it is uh I want to say I this is amazing
we are we are growing like crazy on
Twitch people are resubscribing the
sparklers are here Hal Sparks fans we
had the Midas Mighty here every single
weekday we'd have and it it culminates
into this big pro-democracy Coalition
called the [__] em fam so if you want to
get down on the [__] fam go ahead and
subscribe to YouTube you're not going to
want to miss it I mean unless I get
[__] banned for showing Donald Trump
throwing dildos I showed the video
earlier of him and it happened oh from
the Dairy Queen yeah yeah yeah it
totally looks real to me what am I what
do you want me to do I'm not supposed to
show [__] like that that [__] exists on
the internet and you think I'm not gonna
show it here on the Tony Michaels
podcast so if you want to see it you can
see it on YouTube maybe for a limited
time Facebook is still letting us there
so you can watch us over there at the
Tony Michaels watch it over there and
definitely follow us on Twitch we got a
lot of new followers on Twitch because
it's free to follow us on Twitch number
one number two go subscribe using your
Amazon Prime account go to twitch.tv
slash the Tony Michaels you can link
your Amazon Prime account and your
Twitch account
and it gives us that one free
subscription every single every single
month you got to resubscribe we just had
someone resubscribe here
um just nine minutes ago so thank you
for the resubscriptions that's four
months in a row you got to do it every
single month so don't forget if you've
done it once you got to do it every
month the directions are on the Tony
michaels.com you can also find where you
can download every single episode of the
Tony Michaels podcast in the afternoon
the audio version don't forget there's
an audio version of this too you won't
get to see Donald Trump throwing the
dildos in the audio version though so
you got to kind of listen to the audio
version then come watch think about it
you can visualize it in throwing the
dildos yeah leave it up to your own
imagination right exactly they're big
they're weird you know whatever
if you don't if you can't see it then
you have to you have to wonder like
does it exist does it exist if you can't
see Donald Trump throwing dildos did he
and I'm sure he threw a Republican and
you're watching this you'll have a lot
of detail in your mind you'll really
because I know that Republicans really
love to really visualize the genitalia
when it's not even brought up they are
obsessed with it and they really like uh
when Donald Trump does this weird does
his dildo dance the jacking the ghost
jerk off yeah yeah the jacking off the
giraffes that's how I see it that's how
I see it oh man Mark left us I think he
he got offended oh boy on Facebook poor
guy hey Mark come back tomorrow same
time same place [__]
don't miss it mark You're Gonna Want to
be here I'll pull up your stupid
comments I'll do it everybody else we'll
see you tomorrow Surf's Up [__]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them [__]
[__]
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn headass Beacon
under Santa's bobble head toy
Governor Rhonda's bomb head Joy
it's seven inches tall
two and a half inches
[Music]
that's the best way to say eat your hand
punch your fart box
[Music]
I'm pretty sure
understand his bubble
foreign